what does invisibility mean to you
despite the best efforts of poets
painters
writers philosophers and dreamers we
still cannot explain exactly how the
mind creates invisibility
[Music]
because the process is so subtle it can
be difficult for the unaided mind to get
a handle
of invisibility even more daunting is
the very idea of becoming invisible
the outside world knew of course of our
program
and was told also of our strange
insistence what drew us to the
annihilating whiteness
does whiteness seek blankness or create
it
[Music]
the best kind of artificial intelligence
is that which follows orderly
rational lines of reasoning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
at what point do you think it would be
fair to say should we have comes from
[Music]
distance
the image of humanity has to have a
human face to
really the only it
can you see your past your future for
anything
at all
is
[Music]
is
stop the work before the glue headset
this is not as easy as it sounds but it
is more important than the other rules
even the lightest rays were suddenly
absorbed into a dense labyrinth that led
to shadowy
translucent and impassable regions she
was compelled to enter the labyrinth
no more free than to proceed the other
[Music]
way
[Music]
in its ability to is the ordinary at its
core
invisibility is neither physical or
mental it is an illusory field
created by the mind
[Music]
i saw him what was between the blue eyed
the moon eyed the cloud-eyed men there
he was
the white man
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
you're going to see more stars in the
sky you're going to hear more voices
the world is very different now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are there no spaces here to hide a world
without spaces
where our own is dead an island in the
sun
is the black is the inner world the
island
[Music]
or reason for being invisible this is to
be followed up
with questions about how your role has
changed or not changed
during the three months since you lost
your ability to be seen
you